comme moi mensuel donc dans une demi
heure le début le début du tournoi à
20h30 comme à tous les premiers jeudis
du mois donc à jeudi 6 juillet c'est un
espèce de title tuesday pour nous et
donc ont âprement que trois inscrits
mais c'est évidemment les vacances qui
démarre le mois de juillet beaucoup de
gens sont son parti
celui-ci fait un beau temps en tout cas
chez moi et je crois que c'est un petit
peu partout pareil
donc c'est sûr que ça fait que ça fait
plaisir et que et que vous profitez que
vous profitez de la météo ce qui est
somme toute assez logique donc j'espère
que le stream a bien commencé
si vous êtes dans le coin n'hésitez pas
à mettre un petit message sur le chat
pour me le confirmer ça marche bien chez
vous un petit peu laissé les gens
arrivaient voir un petit peu les
participants du tournoi seront initiés
ne seront ils pas ici les habitués
moi c'est ce que je disais pas
énormément d'habitués mais du coup vous
n'aurez que plus de chances de remporter
le tournoi
yo yo yo yo en vain comment ça va mais
je dirais même comment ça va bien
le tourneur que se passe-t-il démarre
dans 30 minutes je vais je vais je
vérifierai ch la page dans ce soir c'est
le tournant à 20 20 c'est le tournoi
mensuel
comme tous les premiers jeudis du mois
mais bon goût comme utilisé comme on est
en comme on a en juillet c'est l'été
c'est les vacances c'est la plage cd
apéro c'est toutes ces choses qui nous
éloigne des tournois d'échecs mensuel du
jeudi est quelque part vous avez bien
raison mais quelque part vous avez bien
raison
de profiter de vos vacances
alors est-ce qu'il ya d'autres personnes
dans le chat qui s'est passé peut
regarder donc point de suivre de 3 30
minutes
on va regarder dans ce chat là aussi
j'ai deux shoots ouverts
ok dans celui-là on est bien
salut j'ai la patate 33 ils vont jouer
aux vacanciers et aux courageux pour que
l'amante n'est pas à l'heure et bien 20
heures ma montre n'est pas à l'heure ma
montre n'est pas à l'heure du tout 20h03
up
oui du coup chacun puisse avoir cette
personne il faut s'inscrire il faut que
tout le monde s'inscrive sinon on est un
peu dans le dans la difficulté
je ne sais pas s'il ya beaucoup hein
beaucoup d'habitués mais c'est vrai que
un niveau de berre dans le chat de
classement comme ils disent à lui
alors du coup est ce que dans le château
à des questions attendons-nous
tranquillement le début de ce tournoi je
vais vous laisser un petit peu un petit
peut arriver j'essaie d'écrire sur le
sur la page du club
je vais l'écrire sur la page du club
son premier jeudi on tourne oies à 20h30
la personne à qui demander si un tournoi
s'est inscrite dans le tchad pas de
questions comment se fascine passé un
peu vu le tour de france il veut
regarder les les étapes
je vais profiter de vos vacances pour
jeter un coup d'oeil au sprint
enfin quatrième inscrit est vrai qu'on
utilise au moins être à 100 pour pouvoir
faire un tout rond voire 10 qui s'est
jeté un coup d'oeil voir si tout est bon
avec facebook du coup le téléphone c'est
plus simple que de tout mettre sur leur
dit
49 dans le chat n'est que quatre dans le
tournoi les fossés faut se battre faut
se battre
faut se battre à fond je regarde le lien
sur sur facebook à ce pas une bonne
période pour internet les terres des
gens sont dehors les gens ne sont plus
devant leur ordinateur pour le tournoi
il faut aller dans live 1 comme comme
toujours il faut aller sur la plateforme
live et si vous êtes dans le club med
stream vous devrez immédiatement le
trouvais ça des gens qui cherchent alors
comment on peut s'inscrire alors c'est
la plateforme live on me demande des
deux côtés donc sur la plateforme live
et il faut d'abord être passé par le
club et le club je vous tout de suite
vous donner l'adresse du club lead
stream qui est ici et ici
du coup il faut que vous inscrire vous
vous inscriviez dans le club donc sheth
points comme slash club cela bitstream
et une fois que vous serez dans le club
vous verrez le tournoi qui s'affiche sur
simplement dans les tournois sur chaise
points comme le tournoi s'affichera en
tout cas doit s'afficher
si vous êtes donc club que vous
rafraîchissez votre navigateur et que le
tour ne s'affiche pas c'est qu'il ya un
problème
avant
je viens d'écrire sur la page 20 heures
sur la plage du club
je vais regarder derniers membres
les gens qui réussissent à s'inscrire
une nouvelle personne qui s'étaient
inscrits donc c'est que le tour en
marche
on va voir on va voir j'ai mis le lien
est sûre twitch et surtout à ce point
comme cela je tv il m'a dit qu'il a
trouvé du tournoi ouais donc on essaie
déjà quelques joueurs de chez soi c'est
qui est venue de chasse opus 111 sont
tous là ils sont tous là ils réussissent
à s'inscrire dès le tour de france d'un
côté wimbledon de l'autre 1 en huitième
joueur à ça commence à arriver petit à
petit il ne faut pas être premium un pur
pour jouer ce tournoi
tout le monde peut le jouer il est
ouvert à tout le monde
il n'y a pas de discrimination si je
puis dire si le mot n'est pas n'est pas
forcément bien
bien trouvé il n'y a pas de différence
les premium membres premium ou non
premium peuvent éventuellement
participer au tournoi
tout le monde peut participer
ce quelqu'un de très sympa imad à
quillan comment je vais jouer très très
bien je vais très bien et madagh mais
toi comment vas tu
comment ça va pour toi
les halles les oiseaux en face de chez
moi qui sont en pleine forme très
heureux tout à fait contents les oiseaux
qui sont tout le temps très très content
je ne sais pas quand la nuit commence à
pas la nuit fais pas ton corps ennuis
mais quand le soleil commence à tomber
ils sont très très chaud ça les motive
pour se parler je pense le tournoi
démarrera dans dix neuf minutes au
taquet ça me déjà 10 ou satie personnes
qui ont décidé de de jouer face aux
puissants unis saluent kevin je suis
inscris sympa leur tour de castille au
s1 palacin pas sympa on suivra ça
évidemment évidemment évidemment
évidemment en direct sur la chaîne sera
évidemment au taquet pour pour le retour
de kasparov sur youtube on suivra les
parties je crois que ça doit démarrer à
21h d'après ce que j'ai vu mais je ne
suis pas sûr s'il n'y a pas d'horaire
officielle sur le site officiel ce qui
est un petit peu embêtant pour connaître
l'horaire des débuts des partis mais
s'il commence à 14h au sivu qui à cette
heure de décalage
on devrait pouvoir avoir les parties de
21h à 1h 30 du matin comme ça a duré
4h30
4h15 4h30 donc je suivrai probablement
pas toutes les parties j'avais
probablement les deux premières mais
c'est à dire qu'on pourra suivre six
parties en rapide de kasparov sur neuf
et puis les blitz on suivra peut-être la
moitié le premier jour et puis jusqu'au
bout à une heure trente pour pour le
dernier jour surtout si gary et dans les
leaders du coup ça veut dire que ça nous
fera un bel événement les 14 15 16 17 et
18 août
moi je suis très très content ma femme
je pense qu'elle est un petit peu moins
contente pas trop poursuivre gary la
nuit à mon avis mais bon que faire que
faire s'il faut choisir entre ma femme
est garé valeureusement le choix est
fait je n'ai pas compris ce qu'on va
suivre on va suivre le retour de gary
kasparov à la compétition tu peux lire
cet article sur la page la page
d'accueil de check point com
et en ce qui concerne les tournois les
tournois fantastique le prochain sera le
3 août 2010 est évidemment le premier
jeudi du mois tous les tous les mois
tout en tout temps tout le temps tout le
temps on a le tournoi le tournoi le
tournoi le tournoi
j'espère que vous serez nombreux à
suivre donc garé début août qui se
battre à fond
merci au taquet pour les félicitations
sur pour la chaîne youtube merci à toi
tu sais pas si je la tournée j'ai
préparé une petite vidéo sur une partie
qui est pas terrible en fait
guy radjabov si vous l'avez vu elle
casse pas des briques au final cette
partie et non de l'analyse et du coup je
vais peut-être quand même faire la vidéo
jeux pas trop quand les gens vont
prendre mais du coup et c'est un petit
peu marre ambulance et en rire s est
parti en fait la partie un peu pourri
enfin pour y est pas top top on va dire
mais bon du coup une fois quand c'est
préparer puis comme c'est le come c'est
le grand prix comme si le grand prix
fidh et du coup ça donne quand même
envie de le filmer cette vidéo on peut
peut-être materic en scène en attendant
on va mettre ma materi qui jouent contre
hikaru erik maris qui est pas mal
aujourd'hui
ces quatre et demi pour le moment il se
bat bien
on va essayer de regarder non ya pas les
les partis rejoindre quatre jours à gary
ce sera la prochaine étape du grand
duché ce tour à à saint louis et ça
comptera pour le hainaut rapide et blitz
n'arrive à jouer un tournoi c'est pas
sûr qu'ils jouent beaucoup plus gary
donc on ne sait pas combien de tournois
il va jouer
nous ne savons pas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il jouera au moins sournois là donc
c'est obligatoire de le suivre en direct
cette fois c'est le dernier droit de la
carte de gary on ne sait pas cessé son
réel dernier tour on a peut-être eu à
jouer ce tournoi là il va mal jouer il
va arrêter on enfin on ne peut vraiment
pas anticiper avec gary ce qui va faire
mais en tout cas en tout cas c'est passé
l'événement à ne pas rater donc 14 15 16
17 18 août
à mon avis c'est vraiment le truc à
regarder ça serait génial si gary green
pour moi juste pour être tout le monde
d'accord le patron absolu du jeu serait
génial qui gagnerait super heureux
alors déjà quatorze joueurs dans ce
tournoi allait il faut se motiver seize
maintenant tout d'un coup il y en a deux
qui sont arrivés alors que l'univers
sequalum tournoi et ça va tu parles du
temps de jour là ces deux tournois
mensuels
tous les mois on fait un tournoi sur
surface point com donc ouais donc voilà
aujourd'hui c'est une autre étape de ce
tournoi ce tous les premiers jeudis du
mois 20h30 qui pleuve qu'il neige qu'il
fasse beau qu'on soit à la plage qu'on
soit sous la sous l'eau il ya toujours
ce tournoi est tout le temps là tout le
temps le tout en contrant
elle va commencer maintenant concurrence
à 20h30 en commandant 14 minutes
c'est comme un vrai tournoi c'est quand
même vrai tournoi si vous jouez en club
il faut attendre le début il ya le
pointage vient pointer et s'inscrire au
tournoi et puis après il ya il ya le
début de la compétition alors qu'eric
afin de blocus a bien bloqué l'entrée
possible du roi blanc du roi noir pardon
car la cadence ce sera du 3 plus deux
comme le title tueuse est comme les
grands si je puis me permettre
ricard rookie en train de en train de
gagner cette partie
trois minutes plus 2 secondes par coup
donc pour notre tournoi j'ai 19 ans a
finalement tout le monde arrive tout on
attendait que le monde est au courant de
l'horaire déjà tu qu'on n'attendait que
le début du tournoi dernière minute ils
viennent ils viennent s'inscrire au
buzzer
dans cette fantastique
le retour de caspar va vraiment est
fantastique ça réellement être génial
du coup
gary neal va jouer les 14 15 16 17 et 18
du coût 19 joueurs
dix neuf combattants
je suis là ce soir je partage la bande
mais s'autorise ou grobet comme tu veux
tu peux tu peux aussi jouer normal
et alors il sera autorisé dans ce
tournoi y at-il tant elle est interdite
la question qui suit on graisse la
question reste on est à fond pour
kasparov ans comme je le disais manuel
on suivra tu vas bien évidemment
kasparov en direct bien obligé j'irai
sur le retour du patron une obligation
à
alors
alors on et 20/20 courageuse et inscrit
diaries ne participe pas au tournoi ce
soir direct n'a pas décidé de venir
s'entraîner avec nous pour sa part al
que gary viennent tout d'un coup garry
kasparov s'inscrit ou qu'une jouer le
tournoi je m'entraîne je m'entraîne pour
une grande chasse tourtois très
important pour un mensuel midstream très
très important pour moi je serais très
content
alors il ya pas mal d'habitués mais il
n'ya pas berra l'eau ce soir dans ce sud
2000 n'y a pas de joueur pour le mans
classe au dessus de mines dans ce
tournoi du coup le ton est plus ouvert
que d'habitude je dirais c'est plus
ouvert
d'où peut-être nous aurons un nouveau
vainqueur de nouveau un petit peu mieux
dans cette partie eric qui tient bien il
se bat bien
mais car autrement
à
un léger avantage paris suit et vidéos
pour se préparer c'est ce qui lui a
donné deux l'idée de revenir si oui garé
là les jantes
je regarde mes parties joue très très
bien joué très très heureux tout ceci je
ne pense pas qu'ils aient joué pour ces
6 je ne sais pas ce qui se passe sur
cette partie mais je pense qu'il ya eu
comme un problème - missclick
je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
et eu un bug ici quelque part ok c'est
pas tous ici un petit un petit bug qui
résiste bien mais puis en demandant
cette finale et le temps
le temps est un problème du coup le
touran yards en sept minutes
il reste très très peu de temps si vous
souhaitez vous inscrire il faut le faire
maintenant avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
à
ça me va nous sommes bloqués à 20 les 20
personnes qui souhaitait jouer sont là
il n'y a pas d'ouverture imposé ou est
ce les
c'est ce que gary peut jouer une méthode
ruiz un qui sait que le vertueux est
tout à fait jouable
suivent en suivant les ordres de coude
ce serait fantastique une gare il
revient effet que des méthodes risbo
grande chaise tour spécial méthode ruiz
bout je mets des taux de risa toutes les
parties tuent des caches serait génial
très extraordinaire il ruiz y firent et
ses adversaires sur un master est qu'il
bonsoir à tous tous tous pas tout chaud
bonsoir à tous ce sera toi
il a participé au tournoi
attention à lui toi un fantastique elle
21 joueurs maintenant eric cantona
participe donc nous n'avons pas gary ne
participe pas à mme eric cantona sera la
boule à grob voilà le nouveau
participant très très envie de suivre sa
première partie
pollution compliquèrent la partie des
rites ici
quoi prendre damas un tempo d'un primate
vous prend ces trois là se place en c3
dans les buts en à peine cinq minutes
fulla grave on se doute de son ouverture
j'y crois plus trop d'effets ouais c'est
vrai que bout et quand même là avec vous
la gr
oh ça et du coup on est moins étonnés
nyamoya et moi l'effet boom
effectivement victime
alors est ce que eric va réussir à tenir
je pense je pense une car on est à un
poil de pression et je pense qu'il
devrait il devrait tenir devrait tenir
times et de la pression que parce qu'il
s'appelle hikaru n'en mettrais pas c'est
pas sicav ou à tenter de forcer cette
position dans la vie il ne devrait pas à
quoi que tu vas faire fou prend des
trois puisque adam c1 et on est obligé
de faire d'un brin d'espoir hikaru qui
réussit après c'est finalement une
suspicion qui semblait quasi égale il va
réussir à un petit peu pressé même si
pas évident à jouer pour les blancs ça
doit être nul toujours pénible
tu penses qu'elle godbert est en train
de me troller on les retrouve à 20
joueurs
bonjour a disparu du tournoi tant au
début débuter très bientôt
ivan m5 qu'ils vont soir son rival m 5
il reste très peu de temps
trois minutes avant le début j'espère
vous êtes tous prêts
l'impression est peu eric résiste bien
et caro qui essaie de le mettre en
exergue numérique qui défend tous la
dame va revenir en e2 wave 3 roues qui
tente qui tente qui tourne qui veut
essayer de faire tomber
il a poussé un moment f5 c'est sûr c'est
de tourner dans l'autre côté maintenant
pions f6 qui a attaqué et sur 24 aura
d'alger de leur tour bien jouer erik
à
alors que va faire hikaru essaie de
pousser ses pions f et g
il va jouer très vite ça c'est sûr il va
tenter des pièges de partout
malheureusement je pense qu'eric ne peut
rien faire passer tant la pendule et
hikaru fini par l'emporter
ce diable d'hikaru alors nous dit on
avait commencé
21 joueurs
une minute avant le début nous allons
quitter ce match entre icaro eric pour
rejoindre elt horner avait 22 joueurs un
joueur percée n'y aura pas de sas comme
s'il n'y aura pas de forfaits dont la
grande favorite du tournoi en tête de
série numéro 1 il a gagné des points
lourds ne sais pas qui c'est c'est
inscrit aujourd'hui il a joué une partie
et il a fait boum
à
du coup tu vois les buts en moins d'une
minute
alors on est 22
allez c'est parti allez on va suivre
voici je vous la grotte contre gros chat
et on va recadrer un tout petit peu
l'échiquier passe en multi partie allez
c'est bon c'est lancer bunnag robe qui
est en train de lui en train de
réfléchir à ce que je joue un gros bout
pas la grave je rappelle ce que le
savent pas c'est de commencer par g4 au
premier coup donc bonne chance à tous
lorsque ça allez vous la grotte moment
qu'il ya beaucoup de valeurs ce début de
tournoi mais il a beaucoup de mal à
jouer son premier coup donc a fortiori
comme la grob qui pourrait faire pschitt
chic la grob
on ne va pas attendre on va aller devoir
il est parti dans ces partielles va
laisser ça comme ça boume la robe qui
jouent aux quatre doubles à g très très
très très décevant
mon premier coup et 4 ça me très très
déçu
son pseudo nous laisser nous laissait
espérer beaucoup et finalement et
finalement c'est non je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas comment appeler ce joueur
mais il ne tient pas toutes les
promesses que son pseudo données ne
tient pas les garanties
variante assez intéressante 1 contre la
cia il a joué cinq rapidement il est pas
mal après d'apprendre à me prend il va
probablement commencer si c'est prendre
le 5e théorique encore on sait rien le
rappelle plus je ne me rappelle plus
mais bon il va quand même avoir un pion
de plus quoique après 3,8 sur calais
prend ses six sur afu bessette et on
peut récupérer le pion g2 le pion de la
grotte qui va disparaître
à la 15 du tournoi ces trois plus deux
comme les grands toutefois si ceux-ci
jouable de la part de gauche à qui
empêche le rock il aurait pu quand même
fait refouler cette es fou prend g2 qui
empêchait aussi rock mais qui gagne un
pion au passage par et c'est quand même
plus fort
je pense ou et 7,1 quand même jouable
ça qu'il y avait 6 kgs on sait si
s'installer et du coup son pur race est
maintenant en danger
du coup éventuellement qui apprend à 7
qui est prend kayembe 5 éventuellement
jouable à tout moment
donc finir à 19 joueurs certaines
parties sont déjà finies je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas pour le moment
position difficile pour groucha s'est un
peu mis le feu tout seul
retapé unis où elle a oui ma partie un
petit peu étrange effectivement je ne
sais pas pourquoi il n'a que 19 ans et
qui avait 22 inscrits et j'ai du mal à
savoir pourquoi j'ai l'impression que au
taquet finalement été désinscrites d'une
manière x ou y
c'est assez dommage y avoir un problème
de connexion je ne sais pas le site
adule désinscrire avec vous chaque île
as en plus du coup son adversaire se
développer un grand roc se redéveloppe
en attaquant le fou dont vous voyez
cette petite erreur fois ci ce qui
finalement a de grosses conséquences et
d'une position plutôt correct on se
retrouve on sait on s'est mis le feu
tout seul côté noir et maintenant que
faire un éventuel m'en fous c'est cette
oui tu peux obligé mais aspire à celle
qui est déjà en prise il ya plus du tout
l'avantagent de développement qui qui
étaient là pour pour les noirs même un
coup comme fou ces cinq peut être gênant
avec le roi qui n'a plus trop de cases
pas sur soi le meilleur pour infuser 5
mais juste pour dire que la dynamique de
la partie a complètement changé
f3 pas mal il empêche éventuellement kg
4 car il y eu quatre je crois que c'est
foutu pour attaquer mais je ne sais pas
pourquoi je suis vraiment désolé je
pense que c'est un problème informatique
au taquet et du cou du coup dommage
mais c'est complètement fait dominer
maintenant foulée set mais c'est trop
tard maintenant le pion et en f3 fonds
investissent qui ne servait plus à rien
mais mais du coup du coup il n'ya plus
le fou pranger 2 c'est très très dommage
c'est très très dommage pour gros chat
qui s'est mis dans le souci tout seul là
et qui revient en bessin on en parlait
tout à l'heure
éventuellement du fou ces cinq échecs
pour forcer le roi revenir sur la
huitième ranger c'est très compliqué
pour groucha et tout ça part d'une
erreur qui a des conséquences
importantes
bah je pense qu'il y avait alors poussé
5 validé six cavaliers prendre les sept
qui vient de créer un pseudo qui m'a
l'air assez bon prélat profiter il s'est
nourri des erreurs de son adversaire
mais là c'est déjà fini
c'en est déjà fini malheureusement pour
groucha des six maires de bien jouer
quand même il après move il va falloir
s'incliner qu'elle prend 17 qui apprend
à 5 1 ce sera sur échec allez on va
aller voir raphaël rbi rbj pas la
première fois qu'ils jouent ne vient de
madagascar contreuse deux alligators
aie aie aie aie aie aie aie avait
peut-être fou prend âge cet échec ici il
y avait peut-être vous prend à gstaad
échec et surprend à sept cavaliers g5
bon il y avait toujours roi a chuté
éventuellement mais c'était clairement
une option que de venir prendre ce pion
en âge set il a joué tour f1 cependant
il reste assez belliqueux puisqu'il a
des menaces comme cavalier g5 encore on
ne peut plus s'emparer du pur h7l
peut-être un petit fou g5
allez faut se dépêcher raphaël dame c2
et tout claquer fois l'attaqué à yahya
yahya il va tomber aller à deux secondes
par coup en tout cas je crois
près du trois +28 à les dames c'est 2g
et 6 x 6 cavaliers g5 avait il faut
rentrer faut lui rentrer dedans
allez fois ci sonné pour les petits h4
dans l'esprit menaces h5 éventuellement
ceux ci tout à fait dans l'esprit des
pièces deux alligators sont très mal
placé a les traits 177
il est dans l'esprit rafael vous valez h
5 x 6 arafat qui n'était pas x 6 mais
c'est pas grave la tourache un la
tourache 6
le tout rachat allez on y va on va mater
en force
allez raphaël tu peux le faire
il peut le faire a fait l'aller-retour h
si tu t'en fiches nom ne perd pas de
temps allez-vous boum boum non pas le
fou il a joué tour h1 c'est pour mettre
la tour à il change de plan entre temps
sinon fallait jouer direct louage six as
et gagne autant ils gagnent autant que
s'est il passé pour vous allez gator
très très belle victoire en tout cas
très très belle victoire alors que de
chasse ques les chats soit c'est une
nouvelle fois qu'ils emportent jeu
c'est un joueur qui est toujours en
course pour la victoire et li ping qui
est toujours en train de se battre avec
ennahdha que nous avons vu dans le chatt
plus tôt mais c'est une finale depuis
avec un pion de plus et normalement li
ping devrait l'emporter facilement il
peut faire froid ses trois adversaires
jouent h6 il peut tout simplement
attendre petit à petit et venir
progresser dans un deuxième temps il a
tous les coups date tous les coup
d'attendre du monde et donc normalement
li fung devrait l'emporter alors lampe
simplement prendre la tension f4 on
prend et ça ira puisque le pion à ge de
couvrir à g iii au cas où les noirs joué
trois donc la limmat
le roi n'est pas dedans ne peut pas
rentrer dans le carré et donc le pion h
fils adam belle victoire pour les poules
qui se décident alors que faire pire
moment si on pourra commenter une de ces
parties et on le fera
très belle victoire de li ping est très
belle suis très très belle surprise de
rafael br b j très très belle victoire
on va dire et ça alors la ronde suivante
va bientôt commencer
allez on va justement allé voir vers
pierre ducrozet qu'il proposait d'aller
voir une de ces parties contre de chasse
wesley je souhaitais 33 670 qui ne sera
pas loin de la victoire c'est sûr on est
proche de la vérité quand on cherche et
quand on regarde ses joueurs alors
va-t-il jouer une petrov
normalement ils jouent cas ici 6,1 de
mémoire tiassou s est déjà vu plusieurs
fois faire face à l'espagnol dans
d'autres tournois
il joue pas mal les espagnols de chasse
oiselets à ses joueurs joueur très très
dangereux donc une petite espagnole
va-t-il jouer la variante sûrs tayev
avec vous ces 5
il vous faut s est alors tour un protège
le pion eu quatre mondes évidemment
c'est trois des cinq le gandhi marshall
cavaliers pro tour prend ses six des
cats et le gambit marshall c'est le
répertoire de chez soi c'est pas la
première fois qu'il le joue ici qu'on
lui marche à que j'ai jamais joué de ma
vie jusque là j'ai déjà eu des partis
mais je connais très mal la théorie
c'est d ouverture assez très théorique 1
ces versions qui sont très théoriques
avec beaucoup de deux coups deux
théories que l'odeur droid nous
proposant le chat de suivre un club où
j'ai cinq ils contrôlent la case h4
d'am-dam f1 propose des changes des
dames forcément c'est un gambit donc
vers pierre à tous tout à fait raison de
chercher les changes des dames on peut
cependant éventuellement reculer la lame
pourquoi pas en âge 5 voire même en
abscisses et puis ensuite regagné des
tempos via fouet f5 sur la tour 4 et
fois h3 sur la dame f1
alors attention il n'a pas joué d'un
match 4 en tout cas j'espère pour lui
mais joue dam d'un machin car damas cinq
maintenant ici ce que dame de est une
option jusque là l'idée 1 c'est fou j'ai
quatre fois f3 ça peut aller vite après
le pion peut venir angers 4
éventuellement et ça peut aller très
très vite très très mal pour pour pierre
apprécié le cavalier qui peut venir en d
2 1 mais bon on peut quand même faire
foufou f5 et tours 8
ça peut tout de même aller vite il fait
food est un hymne menace la dame pas mal
joué pour 500 salles et en h61 parce que
pas mal de tempo qui était prenable sur
cette dame peut aussi retourner vers g6
maintenant et menacer la tour
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas d'âme g6 bien
pas mal joué 1 dames 2 était aussi
l'éventuelle mans une option dame g6 pas
mal alors sur foot et de yafo f5 cette
fois être il revenir avec la tour
maintenant eu un tour a fait le job sur
la quatrième rangée
et du coup la tour en 2 aussi
éventuellement et surtout j'ai quatre
fous ces deux meilleurs et fou prend 2
qui menacerait la tour du coup tout re 1
je pensais plutôt bien joué 5 5 il y
aura le mérite de menacer le cavalier
donc effet h5 aussi jouable un petit peu
bourrin mais aussi jouable il faut
développer ce cavalier j'imagine de
toute façon on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas ne pas développer nos pièces est ce
qu on fait plutôt cavaliers des deux
cavaliers avec 3 ou cavaliers eu 4 ou
plutôt cavaliers à 3k valises ces deux
cas et c'est de çà me parait c'est quand
même très très long cavalier de
pareilles hyper logique on veut jouer
cavalier e 4 on menace rapion g5 et le
fou du coup ceux ci ça a un peu brisé
pour les noirs que faut être sain tout à
l'heure du mail il faut quand même jouer
au f5 ici un pour empêcher la ce
cavalier devenir ans le 4 et du coup à
la place d'acheter un conte noir et
vendre évidemment ici préféré avoir le
pion à vii et jouer la tour en huit pour
tirer profit du manque de développement
blanc qui ont quand même pas mal de
pièces sur la première rangée qui ont
beaucoup de mal à lier leur tour
attention hein pour pierre on peut aussi
tenter des plans à la fois f3 fou j'ai 2
pour revenir blindés ce rock et
continuer le développement des pièces
issifou f3 par et un coup comme tout à
fait logique ça proposera peut-être de
jouer cavalier e 4 or kf3 aussi pas mal
hein il veut éventuellement venir en
cinq attaques et le pion g5
c'est aussi pas mal joué j'imagine son
adversaire va devoir jouer un coup comme
f6 pour parer ces deux menaces par el
aryath kg 5e à ce qu'à 5
je fais quand même pas mal sens
et c'est jouer si je jouais parti à soi
c'est plus un peu dommage peut-être en
four b3 le retour mais c'est un peu
dommage de ne pas avoir joué le foot sur
cette diagonale en premier je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas je ne vais jamais
joué de gambie marshall n'y avait qu'une
couleur ni avec l'autre c'est pas du
tout des ouvertures que je maîtrise mais
juste ça donnait envie alors à 4 on peut
essayer de développer la tour tours 8
je pensais très logique et on veut
laisser cette tour un petit peu inutile
sur la colonne a cependant peu quand
même tenté en fait des échanges en
reprise prise prise prises et tour à 6
pour venir titiller ce pion c6 et
ensuite on pourra titiller
éventuellement b5 et c'est vrai qu'on
peut trouver du contrat avec les blancs
sur la colonne à qu'elle se dire que
finalement réussi à tenir avec toutes
les pièces alors puis on prend des 50
premiers aussi tout à fait envisageable
fou détroit bien joué c'est un peu le
souci mais ici ça a l'air de tenir tout
reprend deux dames pro tour prend 1,2 et
dames f5
c'est quand même très très dangereux
mais je pense qu'il ya juste cavaliers 1
et que ça tient
ça a l'air de tenir à noter que surtout
reprend 1,2 pourquoi eux deux tours 8 on
pourra reprendre en 8 sur el cheikh est
donc le courage ne marche pas je sais
qu'il peut regretter d'avoir perdu ce
temps tout à l'heure est-ce que cavalier
f4 est envisageable ça me paraît quand
même un peu un peu beaucoup qu'il prend
du fou fou dame f5 c'était l'autre
option qui paraît d'ailleurs meilleur
maintenant est ce qu'on peut faire tout
reprend huit prisons 8,3 g2 ou même rage
et de direct sur orange et de direct
peut être cavaliers f4 et à calculer
mais on pourra toujours faire [ __ ] un
f4 l'idée étant je vais quand même le
montrer sur pions prend de faire dame g4
et d'emprunts f3
mais on pourra toujours éventuellement
jouer fou prend alors ici cavalière 4
clairement de nouveau une option avec
l'idée sur fion prend de faire d'alger
quatre étapes et la tour e 2 donc sur
cavaliers f4 on imagine qu'il aurait
joué tout reprend 1,8 cavalia je suis
trois échecs et tout reprend 1,8 mais ça
aurait été intéressant
alors on va tout pour l'ata côté de
chasse wesley vers pierre qui a pris le
pion à 6 puis on prend avec quoi on
reprend ici reprend 2 f on s'affaiblit
un petit peu mais c'est peut-être pas si
grave que ça la dame va probablement
aller vers g4 après il faut organiser
des menaces de maths à base de la dgi en
bresse 3.2 pour le moment donc tout
reprend 8 prises en huit je pense que ça
va être jouée à 7
non non il joue cavalier f3 il défend la
case de trois cavaliers 3 quand même
crise prises à cet j'imagine et surtout
on prend les trois peut-être à huit
échecs et la dame revient je souhaite
c'est qu'il n'aura pas réussi à mener
son attaque à bien aller [ __ ] en g3
folle tenté pour faire fouler huit
échecs même si ça ne marche pas
appréhender couverte c'est ta seule
chance à tour avec 3 8 échecs et dame
prend et dame prend ses six images et
nous même tour à cet échec est d'alger
huit ans on peut aller mater ici
j'imagine on peut aller mater on peut
aller mater dame g8 et damages 7 maths
ça va mater tout seul c'est pas mates
encore le roi va réussir un petit peu
s'échapper la machette sait pas encore
si ce n'est d'une manière ou d'une autre
à les dames des cinq dames quake 3 ça
finit la partie
alors que se passe-t-il dames 2 voire un
matisse y quelque part c'est sûr d'un b5
maths et s'en sera fini des espoirs de
chasse wesley jolie parti qui souhaite
c'est que c'est peut-être un peu ratée
avec son quad 5 1 qui c'est parti assez
sympa assez dynamique
allez on va les suivre
on va suivre gros chat mais sur la
première partie contre ricoux aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe pourri coup le matin en 1 à
il leur a un gros chat qui rate un matin
on est de nouveau sur une partie
spectaculaire
c'est très très tendue c'est compliqué
f5 j'imagine départ de rick ware et
couple qui fait foi fuite à il va
prendre le pion à 3 ricou aura-t-il le
temps assez tendue 3,5 que ferry coup
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe il était pas mal
ricou mais d'un petit peu craqué forum
de ramener évidemment le roi au centre
pour i oi qui va tomber c'est une belle
partie c'est une belle partie c'est une
belle fin de partie reste-t-il encore
quelque chose à se mettre sous la dent
alors il reste liping li fung li fung
contre eux raphaël b j rafa lui après sa
superbe victoire lors de la première
ronde contre eux allaient gator qui est
en difficulté avec les pièces blanches
liping a quand même trois pions de plus
la le pion à qui va être accompagnée
adam ça va pousser tout seul aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe rafale belgique
oulalala tour qui n'est pas prise par
lee plum mais que se passe-t-il
mais que se passe t'il enfin bon le pion
de passe c'est le plus important est
maintenant on va pouvoir faire tour à
deux tours c'est 2 et venir tous claqué
sur f2 c'est marrant de juste liquider
les pièces comme ceux-ci tour f 6 tours
f3 et dans tous les cas
quoi qu'il se passe sur elle fera tout
reprend avec deux ont pré move et ont
passé trois pions peut éventuellement
gagner comme sans postiches juste faire
voir des cats et pousser les pions hein
c'est juste pour vous montrer un petit
peu d d d idées transformation de ici
tout à fait jouable
raphaël mégi qui peut ici éventuellement
abandonné c'est très difficile
s'il de tenir cette position alors dans
le tournoi du coup pierre faire pierre
qui est qui et pas mal hein forcément je
me sens un petit bug je veux mettre à
jour la page
exactement
alors et on va reprendre vers pierre
écouter un il est leader du tournoi on
vient de le suivre et joue contre 8,7
nunc google donc de haut de tableau
à
du coup floris châssis j'ai quitté le
tournoi sans faire exprès je vais
envoyer des grog c'est dommage du coup
c'est peut-être pire qu pas n'importe
quoi je réponds n'importe quoi je
regardais le chat
ce système de l'undd qui ressemble
maintenant peut-être à une pire qu alors
on va faire du dames c'est toi peut-être
essayer de ramener le cavalier h5
clients f4 attention tout de même aux
découvertes jeu posté par un petit peu
précipité doux et g5 ici on aurait
peut-être pu prendre le temps et
commencer par ses six dames c'est
certain et on avait de toute façon j'ai
cinq sous le coude à tout moment alors
cavaliers à justin qu'il faut calculer
un faux calcul et si ça marche c'est
assez bien joué les maîtres lecavalier
f4 maintenant du coup j'ai cinq est
justifiée pas obligé d'attendre et pu
attendre quand même et essayer de faire
car il ya cinq cavaliers f4 en ayant en
ayant ce fou toujours en h4
ça a été possible tous avaient classique
alors est-ce qu'on peut essayer de tirer
profit tous avec du cailly c5 je ne
pense pas dams est pas mal sept
cavaliers ses cinq fautes 6 du coup
maintenant ils cette nounou qui file
vers la case f5 lui-même qui pour ça à
ses systèmes ses sets car il ya tout
simplement tu as tu un poil dommage
c'est un peu trop trop vite donnés ces
quarts se veut pas dire qu'il est moins
bien mais peut-être qu'il aurait pu être
un peu plus malin
du coup
comment continuer
cavalia si ce qui est assez logique mais
j'essayais de comprendre la suite de
coups que les noirs vont employer ici
imagine cavaliers de 3 pour les blancs
quand même pour le vent ya pas trop de
menaces
- ya pas trop de menaces dont cavaliers
de 3 ha pardon excusez moi du coup il
veut peut-être viser à 15 h 5 mai ce qui
peut vraiment aller sur la casa le 5
pour le moment je ne crois pas position
compliquée
position compliquée il fait ses six
maintenant j'ai un peu soupe selon tous
ses coups la dame en russe est le pion
ses six plus tard j'ai parlé quelque
chose qui n'est pas pas très net dans le
noir
hic et nunc ici et maintenant c'est du
latin on a un joueur en latin kc-45
hockey logique haïssent et capturant pas
sûr qu'elles étaient bien placés en vue
3 c'est pas trop ce que sky vient faire
évidemment ils menacent le pion mais en
tout cas c'est ce sera peut-être pour
faire juste dames c'est cette fois eu 6
finalement deux pions et bien défendu
du coup je ne suis pas sûr de ce coup
à
k4 stabiliser son cavalier
suis pas sûr je ne suis pas sûr faut 6
alors faut aussi c'est ce que ça
n'arrive pas un pion en un coup tout ça
sent que les joueurs ont beaucoup de mal
cette position a pas faire des plans je
ne sais pas si c'est moi qui ne voient
pas ce n'était pas forcément à partit
donc plus difficile de voir mais je suis
quand même curieux de savoir ce qui se
passait ici sur cavaliers prend 1,5
parce que ce n'était pas un pion gratuit
la question reste entière
peut-être des choses à base de foie ce 3
mai peut-être fouache 3 qui était assez
fort et surtout afin du coup vous
prendre cinq possibles possible
finalement je ne pense pas que c'était
calcul r parce que finalement le pion
disparaît fou détroit ok on va réussir à
attaquer le cavalier et a menacé la tour
si j'imagine d'american d'un refrain f 4
qui me paraît très très fort en fait je
cadre d'un projet 4 paraît très très
forte sur d'alger cas d'échec on ne
pourra pas couvrir par dame g5 sous
peine de se prendre tout simplement tour
d'essai toujours quelque part
le cavalier n'étant plus en prise du
coup on va être obligé sur dame g4 de
bouger droit on va dire roi trois jeux
suite il va y avoir d'un point f4 et sur
trois sets on pourra peut-être
éventuellement commencer par damev cinq
échecs placer le roi sur 20 pour
protéger le cavalier bouger le roi faire
bouger droit l'on croit je suis de force
émanant d'un point f4 avec surtout prend
d un truc comme dame prend h6 roi bouge
vous n'êtes pas me croire fils du comte
être directement tout reprendre et un et
garder d'un profit sous le coude
ok les grosses erreurs de deux verres
pierre qui a joué rouaroua h 7 km 5 3
bougez tour 17 donc là la position
complètement abandonna blain déjà pour
les noirs quasiment la toux qui tombe
d'un même si ce quasi forcée 1 ou d'un
le 6 mai 2006 maintenant dame prend et
tout reprend 17 et cavaliers france et
6,6 à tous qui tombent toutes ont tous
tombent tout on tombe tout tombe tout
tombe ça va faire trois pions ça va
faire cher en santé dans cette partie
que les noirs que les noirs n'avaient
pas vraiment un plan st ça se sentait
bas et maintenant et encore le pian le
pion c6 qui aurait pu tomber un puits en
faire tomber un troisième
allez on va cacher le roi alors suroît
f1 peut-être il ya poussé quatre n'est
même pas obligé les blancs continuent
leur jeu flash 3 ne menace pas
grand-chose fou g4 iv avoir juste tour
des 3 août ont des six échecs d'ailleurs
plus entreprenant suivi droit et enfin
tournée trois aussi très bien aller
maintenant il faut prendre effet
regrettera quand même
c'est chose faite autour des 6 on aurait
pu avoir ici ont sensiblement pareil
très haut blanc mais ça suffit ont été
remis roi de droit va monter a du coup
et puis reprendre du roi quand même
allez les noirs vont se créer un pion
passé mais après tour ses sept tours
france et 6 ya j'imagine un peu trop de
pions passé pour les blancs et donc
abandon hic et nunc hic et nunc
je sais pas qu'on prononce qui gagne
alors est sur eric cantona alors eric
cantona qui va gagner après tout reprend
epyon h1 d'âme parce que changer de
parti un parcours d'eric cantona mat
avec une dame on va revoir iq ou
pourquoi pas ricou ricou ricou qu'ils
allaient blanc
eric ou qui est très mal du coup ça
c'est fini
il nous reste à l'est nous reste une
petite finale entre li ping et guillaume
vinh alors c'est compliqué ça va partout
mais les blancs doivent être mieux parce
que le roi est du bon côté on ne peut
pas jouer pour points 4 ici pour les
noirs sous peine d'avoir une finale
perdante
alors on va se retrouver après tout
reprend 3,3 forcé il faut mettre la tour
en g8 quelque part par là où angers a en
fait plutôt un mais il y aura roitg 4
alors tour g5 bien joué probablement 3 h
4 parce que c'était vraiment bien fait
puisque du coup maintenant on est un peu
changé 2 h 3 tours d2 3 5 ha pourquoi
paroisse je sens que je pense qu'ils
auraient pu le roi h 5 et continue dans
l'esprit au moins gagné du terrain alors
on va retourner vers la partie alors le
roi est coupée mais normalement on va
devoir pouvoir on va pouvoir monter
petit à petit avec les blancs alors que
s'est-il passé avec cette tour alors
pourquoi est-ce que la tour est parti à
vide pourquoi n'at-on pas jouer 3,5 ici
pour continuer à avancer tout simplement
c'est étrange puisqu'on a laissé au roi
noir tout le loisir de revenir olalalala
refaire des master class sur les finales
de tours
je sens qu'il paraissait quand même
quand même beaucoup plus fort pour
garder ce roi coupée sur la bande très
grosse erreur de liping en finale du
coup je vais
va repartir alors on continue à suivre
la tête on va continuer à suivre la
table une alors avec une in the indienne
une jeune indienne
la confiance et chercher des joueurs
pour la prod cette ligue tu cherches
encore quel niveau faut-il avoir nous
demande jury chess 2004 plus en fait
salut bucs ce qui ravi de te revoir
stream et camino je serais quand même
beaucoup
ça vient de là mon nom pouvait bloquer
le roi va main mais je crois que le roi
adverse était trop loin pour que ça
fasse nul je sais pas ça fait longtemps
du parvis c'est fini avec le pion de la
bande de la tour devait passer devant
mais je crois que ça devait aller le roi
me paraissait quand même loin je suis
dit je ne regarde pas beaucoup et c'est
pour ça c'est pour ça alors
cette partie pendant que nous étions
partis du coup ça m'a l'air ok pour les
noirs qui peuvent à une image ou un truc
comme cavani 6,6 et puis après voilà
rock qui avait laissé six tours des huit
après prendra et se retrouve à jouer
contre un pion isolé ça me paraît très
bien on n'est même pas obligé de réagir
ici avec les noirs faire quoi que on
peut peut-être prendre quand même pour
éviter que la tour de vienne en sait un
peu peut-être prendre en c3 la farine de
bons choix
ok faut cette fois ça du coup j'aime pas
trop parce qu'il est pas vraiment de
menaces quand je ne suis pas menacée je
n'aime pas trop me déplacer ou est ce
que les blancs doivent essayer de
prendre prendre et faire food et 3 pour
ne pas jouer la structure avec le pion
isolé est ce qu'on peut essayer de faire
ces cinq du coup tiré profit pour jouer
b4 après s'accroche aux pions en c5 un
peu comme dans une attaque pas neuf
je pensais ce jour avec les blancs c5 et
b4 avec 4 quelle énorme erreur n' roll à
la la la la la la la la la
alors là quelle horreur donc irvine qui
avaient la bonne idée mais qui a joué
donc vous voyez hein
l'idée pas du tout correct donc c'est ça
une bécasse et dans l'esprit de ce que
je vous disais je pense c'est plutôt une
bonne idée après faut voir ces cinq
cavaliers c6 pour empêcher bekkat et
tout ça bon après c'est ce et d'autres
questions
mais du coup après b4 olemps lolov ou
prend des quatre qui gagnait sur le
champ quand même à ce niveau là tour
c'est un forcé pour empêcher fou prend
ses 3es dame prend à 3 c'était quand
même deux pions gratuit non on n'a pas
le droit on n'a pas droit à ce niveau là
on n'a pas droit à ce niveau-là de rater
ses tactiques pas assez terrible assez
terrible c'est terrible c'est terrible
it's terrible pour les gens qui écoutent
pour les anglophones qui regardent battu
là je vais allumer la lumière
il fait un peu sombre assez fantastique
la lumière s'allume toujours heureux
la partie est très compliqué cavaliers
prendre je pense qu'il faut aller
chercher ce pion même si ça paraît
risqué comme ça on attaque le fou et on
prépare le rock
ces quatre échecs ont promis aussi pas
mal et on peut peut-être échanger les
dames et faire cavalier prend 1,5
non même meilleur dans cet ordre là mais
que c'est difficile ils pourraient très
déçu avec les pièces noires quand il va
avoir le replay du stream a peut-être
vous prendrez 8 réussit encore à voir
tour et 8 sur cavaliers prend est fou
apsys bien je vous prends des huit prix
pour être quand même super déçu du coup
f4f 6 et probablement quelque chose
comme petit rock
ça va sûrement donner quelque chose
comme ça jean roch prise prise
on ne peut pas prendre parce qu'il ya le
matin est fruitée cavaliers c6 sûrement
continuer comme ça on va essayer que les
noirs d s'en prendre aux pions e5 est
bon les blancs ayant deux pions de plus
dans sa position qu on va probablement
voir sur l'échiquier
voilà petit rôle joué dans l'alabama
mais quand même quand je repense à cette
gaffe est-ce qu'on peut compter cas ici
six direct pour être un peu piégeur avec
l'idée sur cavaliers prendre faire fou
prend qui menacera ici et ici c'est de
[ __ ] le bordel tu vas peut-être c'est
des piégeurs par kelly c6 quand même
pour essayer de [ __ ] le bordel
du coup c'est la position dont on
parlait pied et sa coquille et
probablement tout reprend 1,5 découle
cavaliers gagne un pion alors je le
signale avec un pion de moins mais quand
je repense à se fouler 4
pas mal placés en suisse faut peut-être
direct le roi là pour qu'il arrive en
tête c'est difficile
c'est très difficile pour i7 nous nous
pourrit quatre pays qui est donc où je
ne sais pas comment ça se prononce
j'en ai marre j'en ai marre la
prononciation de j'en ai marre du latin
je ne veux plus de pseudo en latin assez
difficile c'est difficile
c'est compliqué alors est-ce qu'on peut
éventuellement faire fou prend et tours
pour rentrer sur la 7e c'est quand même
une question qu'il fallait se poser mais
bon il ramène le cavalier en d6 il faut
vite s'activer pour les bleus pour les
pour les noirs ne pas cesser fixé par
les sans fermer sept tours cavaliers des
4 x 4 ok il faut chercher avec les dents
à s'activer est ce qu'on peut faire
genre cavaliers deux tours des trois
paraît très risqué quand même 5 il évite
un peu le mal du couloir et sur khalid
et 6 6 passes 3 rebonds jouer b6 en
otage le pion et menacé le cavalier
makeïeff cet échec attention attention
c'est moi qui ratent des trucs
maintenant cavalier 2 qe2 il ya tout
reprendre de il ya tout reprendre de fou
prend et de cavaliers à vii et c'est
fini tout reprend 1,2 tout reprend des
huit ya tout re 1 8 échecs intermédiaire
tourcoing 2 gagne sur le champ à ces
ratés maintenant il ya tous réfutent
échec aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe elle festival
est le festival helga fo qui est de
retour
voilà c'est le fouillis cetc c'est le
bordel de nouveau l festival ô va
prendre pour 1,4 et prend 17
mais ça paraît dangereux pour les noirs
ses deux pions passé sont proches de
dames des cats 6 jouable cavaliers très
mal placé mais si ces six le pion va
passer à assainir ses 6 et 7 6 8
c'est difficile à qui on prend il pousse
pas le pire non non j'ai du mal à
regarder ces finales au pourquoi ils ne
poussent pas pourquoi ils ne poussent
pas pour aller à dame directement
ça aurait été un festival cette partie à
lui tout seul
allez faut trouver du conte fois les
faire j'ai cinq fois les poussées de ce
côté ça sent le cavalier ici ne fait
rien au lecavalier qui fait le grand
tour le cavalier qui l'a étiez père du
g5 maintenant on a perdu pas mal de
temps à l'est
oaxaca et b2 qui revenir ce qui invalide
laissant à quatre essais allaient
pousser comme un malade de l'autre côté
allez h4 tente le tout pour le tout bien
joué mais c'est trop tard aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe allez h deux cavaliers d
un prêt move mais bon il y avait les
achats et c'est fini mais tente à guy
robin qui a gagné il va s'en vouloir
avec les noirs y va sans vouloir quelle
horreur quelle horreur
quelle horreur qu à l'horreur alors ici
chess wesley avec les pièces noires qui
va pouvoir arrêter le pion voilà tout
reprendre à deux tours à 6,1 tout
bêtement trois fuites ou raciste il va
repousser droit attention quand même
chasse western ne pas trop en faire
voilà comment ça suffit aussi comme ça
j'aurais pu prendre le pion en les rois
f6 maintenant je serai bien tous rêvent
de tourcoing s est quand même pour me
débarrasser du pion est fait chez soi
c'est tu sois c'est qu'un toit difficile
un qui n'a qu'un point assez durs pour
choix soit c'est mais là je pense que ce
serait tant d'années temps d'abandonner
pour à sa place un peu même jeu le beau
jeu faire à de laisser la tour c'est le
beau jeu allez on est reparti en cassis
a reçu en commence bientôt
guillaume inkia trois et demi de
machines 3 qui est 3 chasse aux puces
trois gros chat 3
on a envie de suivre peut-être chasse
aux puces contre li ping
sassou puisque vous n'ont pas encore
suivi aujourd'hui le 4-5 cavalière trois
cavaliers ces six noms il joue d66 joue
la défense philidor des quatre on prend
le centre
bien joué regarder les scores de
wimbledon que se passe-t-il kerber qui
s'est qualifié
à
alors qu'est ce que ça vaut ici pensent
encore théorique 1 c'est pas mal on peut
jouer éventuellement aygulf 3g
qu'attache carthage 5 fu et trois halls
alors f3 allé très très content bouger
4h cas très mal joué de la part des
noirs dennis pong qui vient mettre son
fou là où les blancs veulent pousser
serre qui va perdre 1 2 3 tempo 4 tempo
c'est très très mal joué dormi sont fous
là bas il va juste aider les pions
blancs à pousser et à lui marcher dessus
c'est pas terrible de se laisser marcher
dessus
c'est pas l'objectif des échecs car il
ya trois quarts ils assistent pourquoi
pas masquer ces 5
du coup hk du g4 je pense
qui va arriver donc tu as opus qui prend
son temps mais qui va envoyer les pions
je ne donne pas cher de la peau de
liping dans cette partie mieux en grande
en grande difficulté a vraiment ce fou
qui s'est retrouvé en g4 c'était une si
mauvaise idée
c'était vraiment une mauvaise idée
non j'ai qu'attache 4 allez c'est parti
peut-être pas tout de suite j'ai 4 h cas
puisque encore le fou qui qui peut être
embêtant des caïds des cinq ans elle
bien jouer qui est des 5e 5 tête en
premier de façon g4 h4 va arriver tôt ou
tard ils préparent un petit peu c'est
pas mal fait il a le temps il a le temps
de mener son attaque avec les blancs
on a pas mal d'idées on peut
éventuellement même prendre le set
cegeka tâche quatre fous g5
il n'ya plus à plusieurs options mais
prendre cet effet rejet car ta chatte me
paraît logique
ça ira plus ces problèmes de pions
emprise cavaliers à 5
aussi tout à fait jouable on les fout de
toute façon ici prendre en d5 les blancs
vont probablement reprendre de la lah
réfère fois f6 alors ici là ya juste
deux fois pris dans le set et ça gagne
la qualité a les joueurs semblent
fatigués dix chapitres où
malheureusement qui montrent un nouveau
pc qui ne qui ne participera pas au
tournoi très sympa dans son système
michel pitout pour jouer avec
l'échiquier sur internet
grand bravo à toi h4 donc il ya 10 et de
ne pas prendre la qualité mais
maintenant h 4 h 5 sera forcée on va
prendre mètres la tour en g17 le roi va
réussir à s'échapper
je vais peut-être pris le matériel
calmement avec les blancs ici j'aurais
probablement juste repris entre cette
prise ffu g5 histoire de tout échanger
et gagner la finale
ça m'aurait paru plus husky sichi ch 5
qui on prend fou prend on s'est
complètement gagnant mais peut-être le
roi repart en décèdent je ne sais pas et
la partie n'est pas encore fini fini
finir peut-être commencer par food et 4
damas six dans ces cas là voilà c'est ce
qui va être fait probablement plus fort
je ne sais pas
la jouer genre jouer d'un match 6 août à
jouer pions prend vous prend et damages
6 comme ça on interdira aux rois de
partir on n'aura plus qu'à lui mettre un
petit échec l'engin aurait donc
probablement qui on prend et damas fils
ici doit faire le job notamment ça va
pas être le seul moyen de gagner
il doit y avoir fait même pas mal de
solutions diverses et variées ici pour
tuer son opus est donc un jeu répète
c'est ce fou en g 4 2 li fung qui lui
coûte qui lui coûte la partie qu'ils
écoutent très cher emmanuel guignard qui
est bien remonté dans le tournoi il a 3
sur 5 maintenant vers pierre
malheureusement qui s'est un peu écroulé
l'a fait unique roulades après sa
victoire contre de chasse wesley bonne
partie dans ses malheurs en plus
possible de joindre le tournoi comme
nous l'expliqué bishop btu un an tour g1
et seimat
donc je répète ainsi les poudres
regardant replay sur la chaîne youtube
de check point comme l'ouverture suis
pas sûr soit très bon mais la fouge et 4
pour allait partir elles ont valu
remontrer fou g4 pour partir ici vers h5
très très mauvais puisque tu te prends
une marée de pions les blancs n'ayant
pas encore ok ils peuvent te balancer
toute la marée du quinze de la rose sur
trois est donc là du coup la tournée des
lionnes se passe plutôt bien
allez on reste dans les premières taylor
qui on a regardé allez on n'a pas encore
regardé grec zoé sept chats pas du tout
vu ce qu'ils faisaient là on a encore on
encore dans une chèvre dingue schengen
c'est le bordel
elles sont très compliquées grezzo qui a
un point sept chats aussi ce qui a
encore des joueurs à 0 je ne vois plus
de joueurs à 0 quand même la bonne
nouvelle
tout le monde a scoré
roman de chasse aux puces qui est leader
avec 4 sur 5 mhz il reste encore des
parties à 3 à finir une tour prend des
deux ans attention et il y aura fous ces
trois doit gagner du matériel et surtout
reprend les deux il ya qu à l epr en f1
fossé 3 bien jouer c'est cha salsa qui
gagne le matos pour grisogono mal autant
les secondes s'égrènent aya fou prend
d'amener réseau qui craquent la dame
sous la pression du temps et qui
abandonne alors allez avoir tué à
souhait ce n'est assez intéressant cette
partie gse c'est contre raphaël erb easy
qui avait battu aux alligators en début
de tournoi qui l'a mis en pl ace
puisqu'il a il a arrêté le tournoi donc
une belle mise en plus à l'aise de
raphaël b j peut-être peut-être pour ses
8 pour se solidifier pour ce concile
consolidé patron d'am ses sept quarts
ils ces cinq échecs ont leur place c'est
un petit j'ai souhaité qui va sentir
l'odeur du sang ici je suis assez
redoutable il prend alors vraiment se
regrouper c'est bien joué aussi pu jouer
tour des huit ici pour être sur deux
colonnes différentes change d'âme
protégé a proposé à l'efo allait faire
dame ces deux échecs et tour ces trois
bons je pense que la finale est pas mal
aussi puisqu'à les pions doublé
attention plus beaucoup de temps enfin
elle qui fait un gros gros tournois ce
soir 13 185 c'est de faire une deuxième
mise en pls roi c'est qu'à trois des
quatre peut-être mais très très bien il
est très très bien rafael fall qui
représente par lagaf' car dans ce
tournoi ça soit c'est qu'ils cherchent
des pièges mais il n'y en a pas le pion
et sur noir le roi et sur blanc donc il
ne peut pas y avoir d'idée de fourchette
ce serait quand même beau pour raphaël b
j de gagner la partie
je vais les petits soucis avec non pas
avec le site mais plutôt avec mon
ordinateur tour dit j'aurais plutôt
froid c4 en fait ben yahia et raphaël me
dit qu'il a ce pion à les rois sekkat
raphaël il faut que tu fasses trois c4
il faut que tu joueras c4 vraiment comme
ça il faudra pas prendre ton pions et je
vous en mets ya cavaliers des cinq ici
maintenant il ya eu 7 et cavaliers this
is all ohlala raphaël aux cavaliers des
5 mai quel geste plus fort ce qui les
protège et 4,5 mt pas stable maintenant
droit à trois alors pourquoi tu aies
joué ici je ne sais pas parce que le
plus haut maintenant est vulnérable il
revient aux 5 1 il y ait de fourchette à
il se prend la fourchette à la la la la
la
comment c'est possible aïe aïe aïe aïe à
raphaël qui a complètement craqué quelle
horreur qu à l'horreur quelle horreur il
était très très bien j'aurais pu bien
avant les échanges ici quelque chose
comme ici il aurait peut-être plus juste
poussé b3 et puis ramené son roi
tranquillement vers les pions hoya
raphaël b j auj même après c'était
encore gagnant alors hic et nunc chasse
aux puces et the machine pour le moment
trois joueurs à quatre points le secteur
est ce que nie le temps simplement à
briller le temps le temps le temps mais
quel dommage
il était si proche de la gagne après
avoir battu alligator après abattu un
alligator très frustrant très frustrant
pour raphaël fait qui sait ce qui lui
reste à travailler
l'acuité tactique alors est ce qu'on va
voir un nouveau marchal à la fin on
avait vu tu as laissé côté noir
entreprendre un marshal va-t-il
entreprendre côté blanc aussi nous
prendre le pion et de faire face aux
gants dit marshall
alors tu pour n'a pas du tout envie mark
hamill espagnol plus classique
s'il fait prendre le fou en b3 nous
écrirons niveau est quand même
catastrophique
c'est un peu la cata c'est vrai qu'il a
trois points il s'est tenu donc donc
enfin hic et nunc
en fait c'est à ces deux partis là et
ces deux joueurs là ici un qui joue 7,7
sicilienne rosso limo ont quatre points
qui sont trois à quatre points
je sois c'est qu'ils ne peut déjà plus
gagner le tournoi je sais qu'ils
n'étaient pas loin de la vérité et qui
n'a pas gagné
ça me paraît difficile pour les pour les
blancs ici je sais pas tu comprends pas
trop comment il a joué jab sans que les
noirs font juste tout ce qu'ils veulent
ils ont pris la paire de fou le centre
tension qui ne lui prenne pas son toute
sa vie g4 moquer c'est un petit peu
d'attaqué mais bon paraît pas mes gars
dangereux en tout cas pour le moment
c'est un peu juste prendre en prendre
ici avec les noirs et remettre une tour
en des huit pour commencer quel étrange
froid salut cavalière vii matt hockey
mètres la tour en des 8
des huit fois angers cette cabane en g3
qui est complètement éteint par le pion
que j'ai 6 du coût très mal placé
faudrait peut-être essayer de le ramener
paris six auxquelles fois ici c'est une
menace on peut éventuellement jouer f5
ici avec les noirs probablement et
peut-être l'idée de faire f 4 à 6 g4 g5
et d'encaisser ce se fout g5
c'est une première option non caf 5 une
deuxième option dame c6 hanoi à la tour
en prison là je répondais n'importe quoi
m6 un premier point excusez moi petit
coup de fatigue à force de voir des
parties différentes et des coûts on peut
faire tourner cette tour des huit
excusez moi petit petit hallucinations
faut recevoir différentes parties mais
beaucoup de gaffes surtout du poids f5
maintenant jouables peut même continuer
paraître quatre f3 éventuellement
dams et si ceux-ci coup candidats pour
venir chasser un petit peu mais bon
puisque c'est qu'ils résistent pour le
moment il va pouvoir faire f 3 après
tenir en tout cas pour le moment damev
cette date on préfère pions préemption
prend et cavaliers h57 c'était une
option vous voulez ça que je comprends
pas trop le fond l'idée que peut-être il
veut réussir à doubler à prendre le
contrôle de la colonne mais maintenant
f4 était peut-être pénible alors je ne
sais pas mais f k me paraissait calme à
ces pays parce que se fout pas trop de
cases
après j'aurai peut-être réussi à
s'échapper via des huit mais bon ça
paraît que c'est quand même compliqué
mais franc e 4 peut-être maintenant on
peut faire flouer 3 est tout simplement
jouer comme ceci avec les blancs laisser
les deux pions doublet qui bloquent
complètement les fous et puis les blancs
sont peut-être de nouveau très bien donc
fou et 3 apparaître un bon coup ici et
peut-être un retournement de situation
mauvaise gestion stratégique de la
partirai pas que fouet trois infos 3
n'est qu'un exemple mais j'ai
l'impression que les blancs sont très
très content